le gouvernement et christine dalloz
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
finances monsieur le ministre nous
sommes à la fin de la session
parlementaire à la veille de l'élection
présidentielle et à l'heure des bilans
quel est le bilan de votre quinquennat
on pourrait le résumer en trois mots
matraquage échec et mensonges matraquage
vous allez augmenter massivement les
impôts des ménages
vous avez renforcer la concentration de
l'impôt sur un nombre toujours plus
réduite contribuables vous avez menée à
l'égard des entreprises une politique
instable et incohérentes
à cela s'ajoute vos échecs la promesse
de l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
qui aura marqué le quinquennat comme un
feuilleton dramatique
ainsi le chômage augmente de 1,1 million
de demandeurs d'emploi
quand la priorité était à l'emploi les
catégories les inscrits en catégorie a
augmenté en cinq ans de socialisme de
551 nuit le chômeur ce quinquennat
restera celui des freins aux entreprises
l emploi plutôt que de libérer les
forces vives le gouvernement les a
cadenassé
enfin mensonges sur le niveau des
déficits publics loin des promesses de
2012 la cour d adresse d'ailleurs un
carton rouge au bilan du gouvernement
vous avez réussi l'exploit de placer la
france lanterne rouge en europe malgré
une conjoncture de facteurs exogènes
très favorable baisse des taux d'intérêt
baisse de la contribution française au
budget de l'union européenne
le bilan n'est pas bon pour preuve la
rance est toujours placée en procédure
de déficits publics excessifs mensonge
encore sur la dépense publique
loin d'être maîtrisée la france reste
l'un des plus mauvais élèves en matière
de dépenses publiques en europe
56 8% du pib en 2015 mensonge toujours
sur la dette abyssale elle atteindra
2195 milliards d'euros en 2017 soit une
augmentation de 3 125 milliards pendant
votre quinquennat
que pensez de votre héritage lourd pour
vos successeurs d'autant si l'on prend
en compte les toutes les promesses
électorales non financée est pour ces
raisons que le président hollande a
finalement annoncé va de renonce décidé
de renoncer
merci la pole est un monsieur christian
eckert secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget et des comptes publics
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée marie-christine dalloz mesdames
messieurs les députés
vous parlez de mensonges faut parler
d'explosion de la dette mais madame
dalloz ayez l'honnêteté vos quêtes ainsi
dû à nos débats pas toujours attentive
mais assidus vous qui êtes issu du
madame la députée vous devriez savoir et
vous souvenir que durant le quinquennat
précédent
la dette publique a augmenté de 600
milliards alors quand un gouvernement
l'augmentent de 300 on peut dire qu'il a
fait mieux ou moins mal en tout cas de
moitié madame la députée vous parlez de
matraquage moi je parlerais plutôt de
rattrapage
pourquoi vous aviez laissé un déficit de
plus de 5% près de 150 milliards de
déficit en 2010 il est aujourd'hui
réduit de moitié madame la députée mais
la cour des comptes ne dit pas autre
chose
madame la députée mon inquiétude ne
vient pas d excès de vos propos il
faudrait une heure pour vous répondre
mon inquiétude 1 vient surtout de ce que
je lis dans les programmes des uns et
des autres quand j'entends que la
dépense publique doit être diminué de
100 milliards quand j'entends que cinq
cent mille fonctionnaires doivent
disparaître sans toucher à la défense
sans touches à l'hôpital sans toucher à
la justice et la sécurité sans toucher
aux collectivités territoriales mais je
me dis comment feront ces magiciens pour
réussir à tenir des propos de tribunes
c'est là madame dalloz que je vous donne
rendez vous madame dalloz
après les excès que vous tenez tous les
ans nous avons tenu nos objectifs de
dépenses
rendez vous mi mars pour les résultats
du déficit public de l'an dernier merci
monsieur caire la parole